uh lebron in this most unique
circumstance that we're in here in these
playoffs we have gotten
a very rare look into what's on your
mind based on your social media the last
couple of days from social justice
matters
to celebrating kobe's birthday how have
you compartmentalized all of this
and what's on your mind with with all
that's happening um
so many it's a wide range of emotions um
extremely proud of my team the way we
played tonight
extremely blessed and honored to be able
to uh play on 8 24
and continue to remember kobe bryant and
gigi bryan and all the fallen people
that was a part of that tragic incident
and then at the same time having the
emotions of going on what happened
outside of milwaukee you know
to uh you know james blake uh jacob uh
blake i'm sorry jacob blake
it's it's it's what we it's what we've
been talking about
and it's what we're going to continue to
talk about
you know having you know two boys of my
own and me being african-american in
america and to see
what continues to happen with the police
brutality towards my kind
continue to see what the uh what goes on
with the
just the unjust um
it's just it's very troubling it's very
troubling and uh you know we play a
beautiful game
uh which brings so many great families
together and people be able to rejoice
and enjoy it
but at the same time never losing track
of what
what's really going on in our world
especially here in america so
um you know my prayers go to that family
and
hopefully we can uh we can have some
change and it starts with uh
i believe it starts with november i
believe it starts with november that's
why i started the initiative
that i'm doing with more than a vote um
and getting people to understand
what's really at risk and you know the
change that we continue to talk about
change we have an opportunity to make
change
but it still doesn't stop there you know
even with um
whoever comes next so um
i don't know jared it's a lot going on
through my head i appreciate it well we
thank you we'll leave it there lebron
thank you very much
i appreciate it the face of the league